Nasser, what can I do you for, sir?
I want mouse.
mouse, mouse.
what do you think?
is this a pet shop?
to call it a mouse.
you call it.
oh, chocolate mouse.
you want a chocolate mouse? no, no.
chocolate mouse, yes.
gonna demolish.
no, no, no. we say chocolate mouse now.
we haven't got chocolate mice here.
you have to go sweet
chocolate. him.
no, not mice.
most mice, my friend, is the plural of mouse. you see?
chocolatey mouse.
chocolatey mouse. that.
oh, that is chocolate mousse.
chocolate mousse.
you mean. is it chocolate mousse?
Chocolatey mouse.
no, no, that's called.
that's called chocolate mousse.
Chocolatey mouse.
yeah, that's.
yeah. yes, well, you could call it that.
I mean, you can call it what you like, can't you? idiots.
why don't you call it your mouth?
you've got it.
all right, but I want next a party.
pari, pari, pari, pari, pari, pari, pari.
yeah! tomato.
pari, tomato.
oh, tomato puree.
that's what you mean. tomato.
no, no. I must correct you.
on his way. the.
the pronunciation.
the correct pronunciation is Tomato Perri.
tomato Peri.
now, where the Molly are we out of tomato peri? love
tomato peri.
oh, I saw it, right. it's right here under my nose.
there we are.
so, one jar of very nice tomato peri.
shut up. feral.
apologies. on behalf of the wife, Sir. Sodo.
yeah, that's what I say. yeah,
so do. so do. yeah, so do.
oh, yes, so do.
bicker bonnet of soda.
oh, bicker bonnet.
I'll be back.
I'm a very good bicker.
bonnet of soda.
bicarbonate of soda.
they have their usage, don't they, sir? yes, sir.
there we are.
bicker bonnet of soda. say yes.
anything else?
bigger bonnet?
yes. Jewish? no.
she looks a bit Jewish, but she's not
Chinaman. we're not China. we're both Civ. civ.
civ. she's not Civ.
are you? you're muzzling, aren't you? C o v.
c o v. c o v. c o v. coffee.
I mean, c o v. oh, c u v.
what is it? where it always is. by the juicer.
a Jewish. Jewish.
oh, that's the Jewish.
what flavor Jewish would you like, sir? a pricket.
a pricket? oh, yes, a pricket.
what? cinnamon.
oh, Cinnamon. Chinaman.
oh, she's found a Chinaman for you.
yes, I can do it.
what else would you like? Tong you.
not at all. semi pleasure. no, no, no.
not the pleasure.
Tong you. Tong you. Tong you.
turn off Tong Yu.
oh, a tin of tongue.
oh, there we are.
look, there we are.
the Bronx. the Bronx. tongue.
is that the one? yes.
there we are.
what else said a Bee bum?
Bee Kindle, frozen b b.
I'm not talking b b.
I want b I want b.
yes, of course. I want you go out here.
no, no, no, please, not that. b, b, b.
villain them, P.
villain them, P. villain them, p.
villain them.
oh, vila nampart.
villandam. the villandam, p.
yes, I know. I say nice slicky of that.
so there we are.
villandam, p.
now, come on, give me a really hard one. come on.
so now give me.
I want a soup. soup, soup.
now, I'm catching on to this.
you want soup to wash your hands with, don't you?
yeah, well, we don't sell that,
so you have to go down the chemist.
he's a very nice bloat.
he'll cure anything.
Ma malady. yes,
he'll cure your malady for you.
yes. ma malady.
ma malady. ma malady.
for the duets,
the 2 asked at the brink fast
with the C of E on the do ask.
oh, I've got you a nice cup of C of E,
couple of slices of 2 asked
with the mammality on the top. spread on
our mammality. that's a. there we are.
anything else? Kak? thumb.
oh, yes, Kak. very good.
here we are.
one second. Jerelli is a very own chocolate CAC.
that's the one, is it?
is that the latter?
ecology CAC.
yeah, ecology CAC.
Jacology. mousse. Tom or Topari Wicker bond of daughter.
Jewish Chinaman Civ.
apricot. Jewish Dong U, P. soup.
ma malady. and the Kak.
it's wonderful.
free underpants.
thank you. 4 P chains. thank you. please.
no, please, no t chain. no,
thank you very much.
I now go to Habdi Sherry.
oh, Hamid Sherry.
you going down the booze of a quick one. I hear you.
no, no, no, no. boozer.
Hamedy Sherry.
hamedy Sherry.
for the clothing.
oh, haberdashery.
hamedy Sherry.
yes. I've got to get large brass ears for my wife.
brass ears? no, not brass ears.
no, brass ears.
oh, brass ears.
yes, for my wife.
she needs large brass ears
cause her tights are enormous.